[SPEAKER_00]: 3 a.m. on the 5th of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, Leslie, Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've been having a negotiation in the hallway of the jail.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we're agreed that they can return, lock them up, keep their close guard, the extra guard on these two.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that that female in there is magical and the only thing that I think that you need to be doing with her is I think you need to bind her hands behind her back and you need to lace her fingertips.
[SPEAKER_02]: She needs to be able to wiggle a fingertip and you gag her.
[SPEAKER_02]: No gestures with her hands, no verbal components.
[SPEAKER_03]: When I went and got her, she didn't do anything mad, did she?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm pretty sure she's a caster.
[SPEAKER_03]: You'll just have to take my word on her.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know about the dude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Were the guys that we fought that jumped into the water, were they snakish at all?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I could see it in the car.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: They had those masks on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm pretty sure she can cast magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least the ones that I've encountered before, that polymorph me can cast magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she was in charge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not the other two guys, because I killed, we killed, well, I killed two in the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the artists skate through the sewers.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, I just oversee it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I oversee the guards.
[SPEAKER_02]: I tell them to put the damn catcher on her, gag her, and hands behind the back.
[SPEAKER_02]: And when they do it, they need to lace her finger with cordage so that she can't make a little gesture.
[SPEAKER_02]: Behind her back as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of the guards asked you, what about feeding, sir?
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't give a fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, uh, they don't have to feed.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't need to eat for at least a day or two.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've said.
[SPEAKER_00]: Close it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, we'll be back to torture him again, I'm sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, the guy, you can watch him too.
[SPEAKER_02]: If he starts to, you know, do anything that feels like magic, just don't cushion him with your crossbows.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't hurt her, though, yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: We still want to work on her.
[SPEAKER_02]: You good?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've been good.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just wasn't sure if you needed to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Follow me.
[SPEAKER_03]: What?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I leave the way out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, no, I make sure you come on with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, Leslie.
[SPEAKER_03]: It sounds a little weird, bro.
[SPEAKER_03]: You are weird.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, Leslie, we're going back.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want all of us to go back to the Alchemist shop because I want to find that box.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: The three of you walk out of the jail into the main castle and then out of the castle down to the northern gate of the palace district.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's completely quiet.
[SPEAKER_00]: The moon is, I would say, just starting to become back from a new moon so it's not that light out.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, skies are somewhat cloudy, so you can't really see the stars at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: So dark, even though we're not on the thoroughfare?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or is there a lot of city lights?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, there's lights.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are torches, there are lamps that are around.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does anybody besides me have darkvision?
[SPEAKER_02]: And is my dark vision ruined because of lights or lanterns?
[SPEAKER_00]: Your dark vision is not ruined because of lights.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, you can see completely fine up to 30 feet away, up to 60 feet away.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's as if there is
[SPEAKER_00]: Low light.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just keeping an eye out for, since it's poor quality light, you know, there's no natural moon or, you know, no bright stars or anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just want to keep an eye out in case we're being followed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's been a night of activities.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys have captured the Brotherhood flunkies in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So,
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys walk down the Avenue of the Gods towards this area.
[SPEAKER_00]: So by about 3.30 you get down to here and there are a set of guards basically that are guarding the region.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, they're guarding the Burbell?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, just walk up.
[SPEAKER_00]: You walk up?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of them goes, Paul, or Rivero, Prince Rivero, they salute as he walked past.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you guys walk through towards the burnt alchemist place.
[SPEAKER_00]: The air here is still out-grid.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, there have been some chemicals burned.
[SPEAKER_00]: The roof is partially collapsed.
[SPEAKER_00]: The front of the building where most of the damage happened is there, but there are still parts of the structure that are up.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's stone.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, the roof has collapsed, at least for the main room.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I get a breakdown of what happened?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so there was a knock on the door maybe 15-20 minutes after you left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Him and I were talking about the recipe that he's been working on and analyzing, and when he went to the door and opened up the slit to see who was out there, he got stabbed in the face.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fireball.
[SPEAKER_03]: I assumed.
[SPEAKER_03]: The first one.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he went down.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was dragging him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't realize that there was an assistant in the back room.
[SPEAKER_02]: He hollered for his assistant.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I was trying to ask for, like, you know, an exit.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said, the sewers.
[SPEAKER_02]: So then we went down the spiral staircase in the side wing.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they had broken in in the meantime, so I cast my second fireball in the room to give us, or it was a wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it actually might have been a wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_02]: To separate, to give us time to get down in the sewers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Once we were down in the sewers, I had a little bit of time because of the wall of fire, but that's why I couldn't save him, and he died from the poisoning.
[SPEAKER_02]: He would have lived, even though he lost an eye, but it was the poisoning.
[SPEAKER_02]: That black dragon, Sam, whatever it is, his name is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then when we fled, he either fell into the sewage flow or jumped in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think he jumped in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, to get away, because we were being chased.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so they sent two men in with us, and yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, we got out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you have to cast Fireball?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: You were in the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: You were, didn't.
[SPEAKER_01]: It disturbed my reading time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, well, your master is dying, and I need to be getting out of there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gaining brain cells.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: By the second.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Typically, you don't need to gain brain cells.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, but what I need from you is when we walk in, I want to walk in, but I want to make sure that I'm not going to fall through, like, the floor and burn my lower legs off or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Totally.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm like, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: The floor is wood.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not wood, but it's stone.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there'd be no breakage.
[SPEAKER_00]: The wood parts of the building collapsed.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, this is a very well-constructed building for this area, which is probably the reason he bought it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But three of you walk through the broken structure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I will cast a light...
[SPEAKER_02]: I believe I have the cantrip.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep, I got the cantrips light, so I'll cast light, you know, as many times as I need to just to kind of like, you know, illuminate the darker recesses.
[SPEAKER_00]: You cast light on a beam.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It lights up the area.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can only have that one cantrip going at once, one time.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can only cast it once.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but I can always make it go out there and then make it closer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make it closer, twice, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm just saying, I'm using that for a better view.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roman, or Leslie.
[SPEAKER_02]: What area does he keep his box, his firebox, where his files is protected?
[SPEAKER_01]: Follow me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do you walk to?
[SPEAKER_00]: The box.
[SPEAKER_00]: He walks into the bedroom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stay behind me, in case this thing explodes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: If he's trapped it, whoa, whoa, if he's trapped it,
[SPEAKER_02]: How about if Paul investigates first?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: I go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: I open the box.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Leslie puts his hand on the floor.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna back up.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And says some magical words.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes hum-de-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum
[SPEAKER_00]: This is your master's research.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, you knew the magical word.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hover my body over, so you guys don't see it, and I open the box.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's all in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is the box.
[SPEAKER_02]: When he said tomes and stuff, when he said tomes, so we can all see it.
[SPEAKER_02]: He wouldn't have told us if we couldn't see it also.
[SPEAKER_01]: I snatched all the money.
[SPEAKER_01]: He didn't keep money.
[SPEAKER_01]: I snatched everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so Leslie starts pulling out these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Racks of potions.
[SPEAKER_00]: He grabs the books.
[SPEAKER_02]: How much stuff are we talking about?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's like three books.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say maybe eight scrolls that are being pulled out and then he's got like a cache of these small potions that are basically like... Like do I need...
[SPEAKER_02]: I do have tensors floating desks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I need like a desk?
[SPEAKER_00]: It might not be a bad idea to put those on there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I take the oversized cloak off of him and throw it over the tensor's disc and kind of...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I've got the disc.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a floating disc, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll just pack the stuff on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll cover it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can take it back to the palace where it can be investigated or my tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have a tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, we should probably go to my tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, why don't we assume, why don't we assume...
[SPEAKER_01]: That it only speaks because the little language that me and my master said that we just kind of made our own little gibberish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Only I can understand it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So why don't I get five minutes and I can translate.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is with you in the five minutes?
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, I have a question for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're going to be taking these people and this stuff back to the palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do you want it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not in my room.
[SPEAKER_02]: That might be the only place for it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or Lord Jameis can have it under... No, don't give it to Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_02]: What is it you're giving me exactly?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, for right now... Actually, oh my gosh, I do have a place where we can take this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, for right now, I need to know which one of these tomes has the recipe.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what Lord Jameis asked you when I... We'll go to my room.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bring all of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have a spot where we can set up.
[SPEAKER_02]: In the palace?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that what you're saying?
[SPEAKER_02]: Up in the palace district?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the three of you walk back up the hill.
[SPEAKER_00]: The guards looking at you strangely as you pass by with this floating cloak following behind you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You walk back up in the darkness.
[SPEAKER_00]: We covered that.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, we did.
[SPEAKER_02]: We covered it with a cloak.
[SPEAKER_02]: A cloak.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's a floating table.
[SPEAKER_03]: So a floating table with a cloak.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wow, that's great.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm a fucking mage.
[SPEAKER_02]: People think mages do weird shit all the time.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're a pretty weird guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're the dumb one, don't you?
[SPEAKER_02]: You barely made the cut.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're not supposed to be it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Only alchemists.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise there's something in your teeth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Man, he really got to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: That one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your shoes are tied.
[SPEAKER_00]: See?
[SPEAKER_00]: You are the dumb one.
[SPEAKER_01]: I made you look.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's the dumb one now?
[SPEAKER_03]: Anyway, you guys, hook up the hill.
[SPEAKER_00]: Getting back to the royal palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then Paul leads you to his room, which is kind of a little wing off to the side.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's like a whole wing?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like a little wing, but it's not as well maintained or as well adorned.
[SPEAKER_00]: Serviced or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it kind of seems like this is a place you would stick a
[SPEAKER_00]: A disfigured bastard son of the dead sister of Prince John.
[SPEAKER_00]: Still wealthy.
[SPEAKER_00]: He takes you to this room, which obviously is his private chambers.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: I start unpacking the stuff and putting it on a table if you want.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna open up my secret.
[SPEAKER_00]: He walks into his closet and smashes all of his clothes and cloak aside, and then opens up a door in the back.
[SPEAKER_00]: A secret door.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is where we can keep it to keep it safe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, is it just a storage space, or is it a... Just follow me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, so it's a...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys walk down... Do not touch anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm serious.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys walk down into a guard room.
[SPEAKER_00]: That overlooks the bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very interesting notice.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the two of you realize that what you're doing is you're walking in the cliff sides down through some secret tunnel that has been made.
[SPEAKER_00]: You walk down lower and there are very narrow corridors, maybe three feet or 60 feet long.
[SPEAKER_00]: But then you come to a stair that you walk down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then there's another little small guard room that looks over Bay, but you're lower now, maybe 30 feet lower.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you say guard room, are they areas like for archers?
[SPEAKER_00]: Arrow slits, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: These were obviously places to repel invaders long ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are older, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, they seem to belong to a structure that has long been forgotten.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dust?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, not really.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, there are some leaves from the open window slits, because there are window slits, but it's not dusty or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So even though it doesn't seem like it's used, because there's no people or really anything like that, it's not maintained, but it's not like bullshit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, but also, when was the last time the city of Monmurg was attacked and there were people that had to fire, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Long time ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I mean, this is like an old pirate fortification back when the pirates ruled.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: You come to a spiral staircase and walk down and you enter this octagonal, well, you enter a chamber that ends at a corridor that goes forward and you see corridors behind it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do you want to leave them, Paul?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the map.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are the rooms.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'll bring them to there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and then Paul starts going through into this small apartment, hidden apartment.
[SPEAKER_00]: That has a laboratory.
[SPEAKER_00]: It has a bedroom.
[SPEAKER_00]: It has kind of like, Leslie, you're actually interested in the tools and alchemical devices that have been put here.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is kind of a secret construction area, lab area.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much do you get the place?
It's not for sale.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you sure about that?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, but you might be able to stay here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll give you your royal chair back.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you're not.
[SPEAKER_02]: You didn't take his royal chair.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll give you your dog back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie, Leslie, calm down.
[SPEAKER_02]: You might be able to stay here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You might be able to stay here if you play your cards, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because we need you to do some of the work that you...
[SPEAKER_01]: I live in a laboratory and a factory.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not in the fields, not in some royal high care.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am industry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Economics, saving, mass production.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know the system.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to have so much fun writing this.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, let's look and identify which of these tones have the recipe that we need to start, you need to start manufacturing so that you can start earning money.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can we do that?
[SPEAKER_02]: I need everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's all I can say.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: The shop burned down.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it starts with a laboratory.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a laboratory right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why I'm asking.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to take a million dollar deal?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just sign the contract.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, can you use your laboratory?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, you can use it.
[SPEAKER_03]: You cannot use not staying here.
[SPEAKER_03]: You are crazy if you think you stay here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you watch the mass production, the genius, the genius, to sleep on the streets and get mugged when I have a six for strength with a minus two.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll at least need 10 bodyguards.
[SPEAKER_03]: I won't survive after that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I'm okay with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not okay with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're gonna be fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not gonna let her out on the streets, okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: You can stay with the wizard.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll sleep with your cat.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't have a cat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Damn it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so anyway...
[SPEAKER_00]: The weirdness continues for a little while.
[SPEAKER_00]: But Paul, who is pretty tired at this point anyway, decides the best thing to do is to leave Leslie and Jude in the chamber to pour over the tomb.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a horrible idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, it's not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because if you go back up to bed, at the very least, you can go to sleep and you know where they are.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you can basically put a heavy object in the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they can't get away.
[SPEAKER_00]: In a way they're kind of trapped.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which would be horrible if we had a bad chemical reaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't take my stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nobody's taking your stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to look through the tomes and figure out what to find.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just going to wake him up in the middle of the night like, there's a fire.
Sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was Jude's fault.
[SPEAKER_01]: He tried making pancakes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was all him.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he did it in the laboratory because he thought he was a smart mage.
[SPEAKER_01]: He tried to make magic brownies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so, you go to bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.